[Music]
we've all heard legends seen paintings
and watched movies about knights but
just how much has their story been
dramatized for entertainment what role
did knights actually play in history
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives you'll hear
from several experts who cover knight's
battlefield dominance their behavior and
several of the well-known orders
we'll also hear about the events that
led to the end of the night's reign
we begin now in the middle ages when the
heavily armored figure of the night came
into prominence
[Music]
during the middle ages horsemen
increasingly came to be regarded as the
decisive factor in warfare
by the 11th century the figure of the
knight a
highly trained warrior mounted on a huge
war horse and completely encased in
heavy armor
had emerged as the ultimate force on the
battlefield
they were both admired and feared
it's because of his status that chaucer
gives his knight his connect
pride of place in the canterbury tales
by making him the first of his
storytellers
a knick there was and that a worthy man
that from the time that he first began
to written out
he loved it shivalri
truth and honor freedom and courtesy
in terms of people as we open our period
there was still a sense of the division
into three different types synonymous
with the middle ages
those who fight monarchs and nobles
those who pray the clergy and those who
work everyone else
this so-called three orders theory
although articulated in medieval sources
themselves was always more idealized
than real
there was tremendous diversity within
each order for example a king wasn't the
same as an unemployed knight seeking a
patron even though they both fought
a mounted knight rode into battle on
horseback fully armored and mail
he could clash with an opposing army
from atop his horse or he might dismount
either voluntarily or at the hands of
his enemy and then proceed to engage his
foes in hand-to-hand combat
our knight fought with a broadsword in
one hand and defended himself with a
wooden shield in the other
although he rode with his comrades he
was essentially fighting as an
individual relying on his own strength
and skills in hopes of winning personal
glory
and there was a great demand for
soldiers in the middle ages
the wars known as the crusades
lasted for three centuries we'll talk
about them later the hundred years war
between england and france lasted from
1337 to 1453 well over 100 years in fact
and then there were the constant
squabbles between rival barons each of
whom had his private army incorporating
a number of knights
they offered their services to their
superiors who rewarded them with land
which peasants then cultivated on their
behalf
a formation of these knights
thundering towards you with lowered
spears literally shaking the ground
was a terrifying sight
and many who witnessed it simply turned
and fled
so
while conventional wisdom during the
middle ages dictated that the army who
had the most nights would win the battle
there was a catch
nights were horrifically expensive
to properly use all the complicated
equipment required prospective knights
to begin their training during boyhood
so
you want to become a knight
let me warn you it's every bit as tough
as becoming a us marine
you also have to be of noble birth
preferably the eldest son of a knight
himself
there's another problem
you have to start your training at
around the age of seven which probably
rules out most patrons of the great
courses
if you're not the eldest son by the way
you'll probably enter the church that's
another way to become rich and powerful
if you do fit the criteria i've just
listed however your father will pack you
off to a nobleman's house perhaps to a
relative like an uncle
where you'll serve as his page
you'll learn how to ride
how to behave in polite society and how
to fight with a wooden sword
you'll also learn how to carry a lady's
train so it doesn't touch the ground
very important that we see pages doing
their stuff at royal weddings and
coronations
then around the age of 14
you'll become a squire that's to say
you'll become the personal attendant of
a knight
the word squire comes from the french
equie meaning shield carrier because
that was one of your main duties
carrying a knight's shield and spear
you have to look after your knight's
horse and armor and serve him his meat
at the table when he's feasting
you also learn courtly manners and how
to conduct yourself in the presence
of ladies
it all sounds very proper but boys will
be boys and some squires did go off the
rails we hear of rival gangs of squires
burning down half of boston a town on
the east coast of england in 1288
your training now includes fighting with
a sword and buckler a buckler was a
small round shield
throwing the javelin
putting as it's called or throwing
stones a fighting with quarter staves
and and so on
you fight alongside your knight in
battle and assist him if he's wounded
at the end of your period of training at
about 21
you're ready to be knighted yourself
this is a very solemn ceremony
first you fast and pray in the chapel
then you make your confession to a
priest and kneel before your lord or
perhaps before your king
in full armor but without your helmet on
you swear an oath of loyalty which
includes the words sire i become your
man
your lord then
dubs you a knight by laying his sword
briefly on each of your shoulders
and on your neck
this symbolizes the fact that he could
if he chose
take your life
he also presents you with a white sword
belt a token of your purity and a pair
of gold spurs
you now carry the arms and wear the
protective chain male armor of a knight
and maintaining their martial skills as
adults amounted to a full-time job
thus knights had to be fed
housed and supported entirely by the
labor of others
additionally to just manufacture all the
weapons and armor needed to equip a
knight
represented an enormous outlay of
resources and demanded hundreds of hours
of labor by an expert blacksmith
finally those specialized war horses
that the knights rode into battle
were themselves extremely expensive to
purchase to train and to keep and each
night required several more horses
converting medieval prices into modern
ones is is always a problematic endeavor
but it's been estimated that obtaining
all of the equipment and horses for just
one night
amounted to several thousand times the
annual wage of a skilled medieval
craftsman
of course maintaining the night along
with his
entourage of assistance would be a
substantial additional ongoing expense
in light of all this not surprisingly
only the very wealthiest could afford to
be knights
and knighthood itself soon became
associated with the uppermost social
stratum of land owning noblemen
in the book of the order of chivalry
which was written by a certain raymond
lol in 1276
you were expected to defend i quote
women
widows orphans the sick and the weak and
those who work on the land
well did knights actually display such
admirable virtues to widows orphans and
the like
well sometimes no doubt but
by no means invariably
both on the battlefield and off it
infringements of the code of chivalry
were
commonplace some knights scorned those
who were weak and defenseless were
foul-mouthed and abusive towards women
and acted brutally towards their enemies
at the council of claremont in 1095 pope
urban ii called for the first crusade
hoping to stop up what he along with
many clergy and pilgrims thought was a
crack in the dam of church power
urban set the tone for all the crusades
to follow drawing on the deep traditions
of othering and demonology to gin up
enthusiasm for war
he called the turks an accursed race
utterly alienated from god
between 1096 and 99 urban's christian
knights convened at constantinople and
fought to claim nicea d'orlium and
eventually antioch
these were sites central to sacred
narrative and institutional power alike
and this reminds us of how important
controlling history and place is to
sacred violence with holy war this
reclamation is seen as spreading the
will of the divine sovereign in an
earthly campaign that contributes to the
cosmic one
there was also a shift in battlefield
ethics that's illustrative as religion
scholar charles kimball notes christian
soldiers were once expected to atone for
any killing that they did but with the
crusades they displayed muslim heads
like trophies and understood that on
some level they were actually expiating
their sins by fighting that's a big
shift
the turks weren't even in control of
jerusalem any longer by the time
crusaders arrived nor apparently was
there much friction between the
different religious groups that
worshipped there
but nonetheless crusaders
indiscriminately killed city dwellers
after they breached the gates in july
1099.
according to the historical account
chronicled by raymond vajel they burned
the great synagogue and sacked the
temple mount
after muslims worshipping there fled
into the al-aqsa mosque they had to pay
ransom to get out and despite this they
were slaughtered upon their exit
subsequent crusades hardened this kind
of mindset but they were extremely
inconsistent in terms of the church's
military success
a templar was an utterly new kind of
knight and that he was also a monk
it was one thing for the pope to send
secular fighting men to defend and
protect the church through force of arms
it was quite another for him to sanction
an order of monks who were given license
to act like knights
the knights templar were initially
founded by a man named hugh of payne
along with eight companions around 1118
and their stated goal was to offer
protection to pilgrims who were
traveling to jerusalem
they did this not only by serving as a
kind of bodyguard for those pilgrims
passing through palestine but also by
cleverly coming up with a way to remove
the need for pilgrims to carry a lot of
money and other valuables with them
they came up with a very modern idea
which was essentially a very early form
of the atm
a pilgrim traveling to the holy land
could deposit his money at one of the
templar strongholds to be found
throughout the european west
the amount he had deposited was an
inscribed encode on a piece of vellum or
parchment which could be decoded only by
a member of the order on the other end
in jerusalem
the pilgrim could then withdraw the
amount of money he had deposited before
his pilgrimage
once he arrived at his final destination
as a further mark of their high and
unusual status the king of jerusalem at
the time baldwin ii gave them as their
headquarters part of the royal enclosure
on the temple mount hence the name
templar
perhaps even more importantly one of the
most important religious figures of the
day bernard of clairvaux a cistercian
monk and abbott
further legitimized them by writing
rules for their order and the templars
adopted as a uniform the white robe of
the cistercians with a red cross
emblazoned on the front
at the height of their existence it is
estimated that there were about
20 000 templars divided roughly into
three groups the knights responsible for
overseeing the safety and security of
pilgrims in the holy land
priests who attended to the religious
needs of the order and commoners who
helped with the day-to-day running of
the templars quite lucrative banking
empire
they soon amassed wealth and power on a
massive scale something that
worried many rulers particularly the
king of france and this in turn led to
their persecution and the eventual
dissolution of their order in the 14th
century
a fact which meant that their property
and money could be confiscated and
enrich the coffers of others
particularly the french monarchy
this is also meant that any number of
conspiracy theorists have been on the
hunt for the so-called templar treasure
and people like the writer dan brown
have made something like a billion
dollars writing books like the da vinci
code
and let me just pause here and tell you
i really don't think there is a vast
secret templar order still in existence
that is pulling strings and levers all
over the world because if there were
humanity would be in much better shape
than it seems to be at the moment
but still one could always hope and
that's the point right
the templars were not the only new order
of knights to be created as a direct
result of the crusades two others the
knights hospitaler and the teutonic
knights are worth mentioning
the knights hospitaler were formed
around the same time and out of the same
impulse as that which led to the
founding of the knights templar namely
to offer assistance to pilgrims who had
traveled to the holy land while the
templars focused more on protecting
pilgrims from theft or violence the
hospitalers concentrated on caring for
those who became ill while in jerusalem
and as you can imagine
since the journey to jerusalem was
arduous and many people set out on
pilgrimage for the express purpose of
seeking relief from various ailments and
afflictions there was a significant need
for medical assistance for many of those
pilgrims who eventually made it to
jerusalem
the hospitalers venerated poverty
subjecting themselves to the extremes of
an impoverished life but in contrast
they treated all of the sick in their
hospitals no matter their rank or status
as if they were great lords or noblemen
of particular note are the lavish and
rich diets all patients were fed
the hospital of saint john was run on a
staggering scale with enough beds for 2
000 patients and it had wards that
divided the sick by gender and even by
medical specialty for example one of the
wards seems to have been devoted to
obstetrics
within 50 years of their founding the
knights hospitaler like the knights
templar had become a military order of
monk nights with a division of ranks
those who tended to the ill in the
hospital and those who fought on behalf
of the order
while the templars wore a white tunic
with a red cross the knights hospitaler
were easily identified by their black
tunics and white crosses
the last of the new orders of knighthood
to result from the crusades were the
teutonic knights this order was
established later than the templars and
the hospitals closer to the end of the
12th century but again like the other
two orders the impetus for their
existence came from a desire to help
those in need
in this case the teutonic knights set
themselves the task of caring
specifically for injured crusaders
the age of chivalry lasted from about
eleven hundred to fifteen hundred
and long before that however knights in
armor were becoming militarily
obsolete
chaucer's knight is already one of a
dying breed
it's estimated that in his day there
were no more than one thousand nights in
the whole of england supported by about
three times as many squires and that was
down from six thousand nights in the
reign of henry ii 11 54 to 1189
one of the factors that had brought
about a reduction in their ranks was a
phenomenon that derived from the other
side of history the common soldier
provided with nothing more sophisticated
than a longbow and a quiver full of
arrows
the first battle to be decided by the
longbow was cressi in 1346 which the
english won against the french
it's been estimated that in the first
five minutes of the battle the english
bowmen were able to unleash five
thousand arrows thereby creating havoc
in the ranks of french knights
the longbow used with great success by
the english in the hundred years war
even became a point of national pride
and the english boasted the skill and
training required to fire it effectively
in 1549 english bishop hugh latimer
proclaimed
men shall never shoot the longbow well
except that they be brought up in it
the pull of the longbow is 80 pounds
requiring noteworthy strength as well
heavily armored pikemen also filled the
king's ranks tightly packed into
formation
unlike our noble knight the role of the
pikemen was largely defensive and
required almost no training
these pikemen would place the butt of
their weapons into the ground sticking
out from the earth at a 45 degree angle
and then they would prop them on the
backs of the men in front of them
their ranks were virtually impenetrable
by enemy cavalry and infantry
by the early 16th century swiss spanish
german and italian armies had shortened
the pikes and developed complex
maneuvers to utilize pikemen offensively
these operations required more extensive
drilling to ensure that the troops moved
properly within their formations
south of the alps as we know feudalism
didn't feature prominently although
lordship did
during the italian renaissance courtiers
were expected to perform military
service as part of their wide skill set
devoted to the service of their princes
mercenaries were far more in evidence in
the south as republics prosecuted their
wars and mercenary captains condotieri
gained fame
wealth and even political authority for
their abilities on the battlefield
so now let's fast forward
the soldier of the mid 17th century was
a far different specimen than the
warriors we've just been tracking
no longer the loyal knight or courtier
of renaissance kings and princes nor the
older style mercenaries serving the
republics this later soldier was in many
ways a tool for the early modern state
he wasn't born to military pursuits but
instead found himself either joining
voluntarily in hopes of bettering his
personal condition or being forced to
enter service because of his meager
station in life or perhaps because a
criminal past limited his opportunities
even soldiers for hire weren't drawn
from the upper tiers of society or in
possession of any lengthy preparation
for a career in the military
our soldiers training was condensed he
didn't need substantial skills to use
his weapons
and most of his exercises involved
drilling to ensure precise movement in
formation with his fellow soldiers
as an individual our soldier wouldn't be
a particularly effective weapon
his success was instead dependent on his
unit as a whole
muskets and archibuses had replaced bows
and arrows and even a tripod was used to
steady the gun
still these firearms were inaccurate
a smooth bore and a round shot meant
that even perfectly aimed projectiles
took off and wildly unpredictable paths
taking the time to aim carefully and
then fire was largely a wasted effort so
training troops and how to use these
weapons was relatively limited nearly
anyone could fire these weapons with
virtually the same effect
officers were still drawn from the
highest social ranks but military
service had ceased to be the privilege
of the elites
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here